Let's continue to honor Chicago
for a tasty little bite of food news!
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
(audience clapping)
Audrina, you were saying...
That's right, Drew. Okay, so in Logan square,
Chicago has lots of neighborhoods.
One of them is Logan square.
You're so ready, Ross.
My God, look at this.
We've got an incredible ice cream spot.
It's called Pretty Cool Ice Cream Shop.
It says it in the name.
It's the creation of renowned pastry chef, Dana Cree.
And guess what?
Dana's here with us this morning!
Dana!
Hello Dana!
(audience clapping)
And Dana, you are totally matching the pink,
that is the beauty of your shop in Chicago.
It just stands out on the corner.
It's all pink, balloons, it's fun.
I bet it's a real Instagrammable place too.
It is smart.
Social media.
Tell us what you're doing for Halloween.
Well, my staff dubs our shop, "Pretty Ghoul Ice Cream."
(people laughing)
Every October and we do,
we like to go big or little.
We do little trick-or-treat pops
based off of trick-or-treat candies,
like, this year we're doing a Snicker treat,
but we're also really leaning into the ice cream
and doing an ice cream sandwich
complete with a bloody eyeball in the center.
Oh, yes!
Oh!
I love that, you guys,
I've tried the kettle corn,
I've done the peanut butter potato chips, they've got funds.
Okay, Drew's like-
Drew's in.
"It's time to go in."
Oh my gosh!
I know. Okay, now I want to try some.
Wow, this is incredible!
I got the strawberry shortcake. It's amazing!
Oh my goodness.
Wow.
Thank you.
So as you guy get to taste some of it...
I'm doing rainbow chip because I'm that gay. Sorry.
(everyone laughing)
I just opened it.
All right. Let's see if I can get it up.
Okay, so we have S'mores here.
You talked about the Halloween flavors.
Let's talk about something that's amazing.
It's that, it's a giving back component.
You guys do for a cause
where a dollar sold from each pop goes to an organization.
We know that in Chicago, we need the hope,
we need grassroots organizations that are on the streets,
helping our communities.
How are you guys taking part in that?
So every month we create a special flavor
and we donate a dollar per pop
to a local organization that's helping lift up
a little corner of our community,
not a big charity with the big galas,
but a small group of people
dedicated to lifting up a part of the community
that we might not otherwise know about.
And this month we have a very special flavor,
which is actually kind of a surprise for you.
We made Drew's Barrymore cheesecake.
(Drew gasps)
Yes!
(audience cheering)
Have you ever had an ice cream named after you?
No.
Aww.
We put your, one of your dogs on the cover too.
Aww!
Is that Douglas?
Let's see.
Oh my gosh. Look at how cute this is.
(audience clapping)
I am...
And-
So sorry, Audrina.
So there's one thing on here
that says, and I would love for you
to talk about this-
Sure.
it's supporting Girls Rock Chicago.
So, Drew, your flavor is going to go to Girls Rock,
can you talk about-
what Girls Rock does.
Sure.
Yes. So Girls Rock Chicago is an organization for girls,
transgender youth and gender expansive youth
that provides musical education, instruments,
and they do this really cool band camp in the summer.
And they have scholarships available.
And the money that we donate to them
will help fund some of the musicianship
that they provide for kids
who really need a boost of self-esteem
and can get that through music.
(audience cheering)
Yes, I love that!
We love that!
I am all about this.
This really speaks to me personally.
I do think that when we get girls involved in,
you know, extracurricular things like sports and music,
it's just so important for their focus and their self-esteem
and, you know, accountability
and being able to actually work with other people.
There's like literally nothing
that doesn't come out of it that isn't positive.
So, thank you for choosing that.
You get me, you know me, you see me, this is such an honor
and I personally want to donate $5,000, obviously.
Because...
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
(upbeat music)